hey guys it's just stayed and it has
been a few weeks since I got the iPad
pro and I'm not gonna lie to you I never
really used to use my previous I've had
very much at all its massive
as you can see it is much bigger so
carrying this thing around it was always
like such a process this one is
obviously a little bit smaller and I
love the new keyboard folio I love the
way that I'm able to adjust this a huge
thank you to LastPass for sponsoring
this video I'd worked with them
previously on another video and I am so
appreciative because I've actually used
LastPass for quite a while it's one of
those things that you don't realize you
need until you have it and then you're
not sure how you've ever survived
without it so since we're doing it
what's on my iPad that is one of the
first things that I did download on my
iPad because what LastPass is is it
basically will save all of your
passwords and it'll make them all unique
passwords so obviously you don't want to
have the same passwords on every single
website but you also don't want to have
to remember all of those passwords in
auto-generate the usernames and
passwords in all of your applications on
your iPad Android phone desktop if
you're one of those people that has
multiple devices and things are
everywhere you don't want to have to
remember your passwords this is
absolutely perfect and it's been such a
huge lifesaver so thank you last fast
for sponsoring this video you guys are
amazing and thank you for being a thing
because you've definitely made my life a
so much a less stressful like everything
about it I'm just so into it I've been
doing emails I've actually been writing
back to emails because of my iPad like I
don't like doing email but just
something about this just feels so right
like just look at it okay well maybe
that's not a very good justification I
was saying that I like the right back to
emails cuz it does I have 127,000 did I
have it read it's okay welcome to my
video so I guess in today's video I just
wanted to talk about my iPad how much
I'm loving my iPad and what is on my
iPad look at that I was getting the
Apple pencil it was like hey do you want
to add on the free engraving and it was
like sure I'm only spending a lot of
money for the iPad I might as well get a
free engraving on my pen let's get into
what's on my iPad one of the things that
I've actually really enjoyed and it's a
I haven't done in so long is drawing on
the iPad I never really drew much on the
iPad before I have a background in
graphic design so I used to do a lot of
illustration I used to do a lot of
design typography work I definitely do
way less of that I feel like just
downloading procreate was one of those
things that it unlocked something that
had been missing for a long time I was
like oh this is actually really fun so
I've been traveling a little bit the
past week so let me show you some of the
things I just connect this so my
drawings aren't really that good it's
just kind of fun this is I don't know
what we're gonna call this let's call
this I don't know I'm not gonna try to
come up with a name for it this one's a
little a little violent he's having a
bad day
this is how I felt this one I was
actually on a plane coming back from New
York so I'm not really sure but this was
sort of in flight inspired this is one
that I started last night no no
procreate is pretty fun I feel like a
lot of people I know use that and it's
something that I've kind of found very
easy to use so you guys have any other
drawing your illustration apps that you
guys use leave those in the comments
below I would love to check those out I
guess we'll just start with what's on
the iPad we've got my calendar we've got
the camera we've got the Notes app we've
got the settings and inside of here this
is where just I threw everything that I
probably wouldn't actually use contacts
FaceTime clock maps home stocks news
iTunes Store books apps or TV reminders
find friends clips Apple Store photo
Buhi note numbers GarageBand measure
iTunes U voiceover you get the point
Instagram like come on can you just can
you not like can you just freakin like
make an Instagram outlook what is this
so excited what's up girl all right well
what have I been up to why this freaking
Sadler's pages for writing iMovie
procreate we talked about fortnight
tweet bottom of the Twitter app luma
fusion this is actually something that a
lot of you guys recommended to me this
is a video editing app and I am so
excited to try this out am I going to
become an iPad vlogger okay I see you
alright well I'm gonna be spending some
time with this application this is so
great
anyway snapchat so anybody use LastPass
Adobe Rush this is also another video
editing app I haven't tried this yet on
the iPad but I feel like a lot of people
have said that luma fusion is basically
final cut for iOS so next up we have IG
TV not even logged in so why even bother
it Spotify you may be like just seeing
an aren't you an Apple music girl of
course I am Apple music when I'm playing
music through my home pods but it's
weird because mostly when I'm on the go
I kind of listen to Spotify I just feel
like I have all my playlists there my
sister and I also have a share playlist
that we had songs too so I just have
never been able to fully let go a
Spotify because I've actually really
loved a spot it's kind of been like a
huge part of my life for such a long
time because I was one of the first ones
it at first there was another very few
people in the United States that had
Spotify before it actually came into the
United States so I feel like that's a
weird flex but okay Pandora I don't know
what it is but like for Panda like I
just refused to pay for Pandora
streaming I will listen to the ads I
don't mind the dumbest things ever we
get I will refuse to buy Pandora this is
called a plant ale I saw a demo of this
I actually haven't got a chance to use
this but I just downloaded it because I
wanted to show it to you guys it's this
app that will basically show you so in
depth different types of plants it's so
fascinating
girl aiming yeah oh my gosh look at this
the seeds are dispersing hey Justine
just don't know what you do for fun Oh
watch plant AR so it'll show you the
different effects of pH levels of
different temperatures and it's so
realistic the pH is 14 if the water is
high sunflower seeds are remarkable mmm
that should say remarkably tough but I
posted a picture of my dog and said he
was majestic and spelled majestic wrong
so I can toggle let's do the AR plant
because this is what I think is freaking
fantastic a little boy playing oh my
gosh look at this there's a plant so if
you're wondering where my desks what
don't ask questions
I'm redoing my office again just and I
can get rid of those fibers
hey can you see all those iPhone
ten-hour boxes oh my god sometimes that
question what's wrong with me cut the
flower look on the debate this is market
silly so I can actually walk you can't
see me because want to go off camera now
walk up to this plant and actually get
into it look at this I'm watching this
be pollinate and not only gonna go
around it so this is where I was filming
this is crazy
I'm so into this I don't know if you
guys know or not but like I have this
weird obsession with bees
oh it's telling me to tap on the be my
god this is Wow
I am tripping now I'm inside I am inside
the flower so the fact that I am
actually doing all of this like and
screen recording at the same time it's
pretty incredible if his iPad is
honestly so incredible like I love this
thing so much it makes me really happy
anyway the bees back this looks so real
that I don't know what's real anymore
and what's not thank you guys so much
for watching interview has enjoyed this
quick little look at what's on my iPad I
would love to hear from some of you guys
if you got an iPad what do you think are
you loving it I
loving it I haven't even watched any
movies or content like I didn't even
download netflix yet like I've actually
just been working and drawing and it's
been super refreshing I feel like I have
been spending a lot less time watching
content and in my free time I'm
basically just creating content or going
outside and that's been so incredible
like I used to watch so much Netflix
that I was concerned about my health and
well-being so that has been my 2018 goal
was to not be a lazy heard on the couch
so far so good
but I'm looking forward to 2019 because
I really want to start doing a lot more
fitness stuff which brings me to what I
actually used to use this iPad for who
was watching fitness videos I always
watched a bunch of videos from kasi I
used to do Brooke Burke body workout
which is one of my favorites she has a
bunch of really cool ones that you can
do and now recently I've started doing
core power yoga so they also have an
on-demand app which I should probably
actually download and add that to my
iPad I still like to keep finding apps
that I haven't downloaded yet so this is
still an incomplete so this is still
sort of incomplete but for the most part
that is what I've been using well I've
been rambling enough I will see you guys
later
[Music]